-My first guest
is an entrepreneur,
a best-selling cook-book author,
and a social-media icon.
We're gonna get to that.
She's also one of our favorites.
You can check out
her new online store
Cravings Shop
at cravingsbychrissyteigen.com
Here is Chrissy Teigen!
Ahh! Come on!
-Thank you! Whoo!
-Look at you.
-Can I -- I need to walk out.
-I know. Maybe we can, like --
-It makes me sad. It's okay.
-We can get you some
walk-out music for that.
Come on.
-I'll trip over something.
-Thank you for doing this.
-Hi.
-You look fantastic.
I actually miss
seeing your face.
-Thank you.
-I wanted to ask you about this.
You were one of the 13 people
that the President --
President Biden
followed on Twitter
with the official
@POTUS account.
I was so excited that you --
I was like, "This is so cool."
'Cause, honestly, you're so
refreshing and fun on socials.
And you were very excited
about it, too.
But then a few weeks later --
-So excited.
-And this is why I love you --
You asked the President
to unfollow you.
Do you remember --
-[ Laughs ]
-Do you remember
the exact moment you thought
that that was a bad idea to have
President Biden follow you?
-The second it happened,
I was like, "Oh [bleep]."
And I truly -- I think
I sent like two tweets --
Sorry. Sorry.
I sent like two tweets
in, like, two weeks,
and people were worried.
They were like,
"What is going on?"
And, like, listen, I know --
I don't believe
that he thought -- maybe --
I don't believe he's like Trump
and actively
really scrolling through,
but it was so amazing
that he followed me
'cause I had been shunned
for -- for four years.
I couldn't see anything
that was being said, and I --
So it was -- it was --
I loved the statement of that.
But then it just became
too much.
And, also, when you're on that
list, a bunch of weird people
go to his account,
and they don't know you at all,
so they're like,
"Who's this chick?"
And then they come to my page,
and it's just a hellhole.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, please.
-So it was like --
It was really --
It was so much better.
Yeah, so life is better now.
-Were you so excited
at the inauguration?
Was that -- Or was it just
freezing or was it both?
-Oh, inauguration was freezing
and amazing and beautiful.
And I didn't know
that John's performance
at the Washington Monument
was a secret,
so I Instagrammed
the whole thing,
like, the day before
for rehearsal.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
-And then I got in trouble.
-"Oops." [ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
I remember I was so scared
'cause I --
We ran into Katy Perry after.
And I always say dumb things.
Like, I always get so nervous
and I say faux pas.
I hadn't seen Katy for so long.
And I was like, "Oh,
I typically hate fireworks...
but that was, like, amazing.
That was beautiful."
And then I think
she heard that I said
I hate "Firework,"
like, the song.
-Yeah. Like, "That's my song."
-And so -- I know!
And I wanted to die!
I felt so bad.
-"That's not what I meant."
-I was like,
"No, no, no, not 'Fireworks.'"
Ugh! I always do that.
-But I kind of agree with you
on fireworks.
I think they go on
a little too long for me.
-Yes. They don't -- Yeah, it's
like bad improv or something,
and it's like two minutes
too long.
And I don't get fountains,
either.
Fountains and fireworks
are just two nos for me.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah. Fountains.
I wouldn't invest in a fountain.
I don't mind looking at one.
I just don't -- I don't if I --
-I don't get it.
I just don't get -- The Grove.
The people at the Grove
that sit around and take
pictures around the fountain --
It's like -- It's a hose.
I don't get it.
-I want to talk about
"Cravings."
I want to talk
about your cookbook.
You're finishing up
your third cookbook.
Congrats on this.
-Yeah, thanks.
-There's going to be 100 recipes
in this thing.
-I had 99 recipes,
and so, for 100, I just, like,
buttered a bunch of Gardetto's
and stuffed it in a pita.
And then it was supposed to be,
like, a joke recipe,
but then we --
it's actually really good.
-Oh, really?
-But I promise the rest
of the recipes are really
serious and they're good.
-No, I follow you,
and I see what you do.
You actually --
You go for it, by the way.
And I love
that you test everything.
Can you talk about the mandolin
and trying that for the --
-Oh!
-Was it Super Bowl Sunday?
-That was the Super Bowl.
-Yeah.
-Super Bowl Sunday, John --
I brought a mandolin at Ralph's,
and we were making
scalloped potatoes.
And John was watching the game
and doing the mandolin,
and you just --
That's a big no-no.
You can't watch anything
while doing it.
And he sliced off
the tip of his finger.
And fingers are all John needs
in life, basically,
so I was like, "You idiot!"
He started running it
under water,
and he was like, "I'm not gonna
go to the emergency room.
I want to watch the game."
So it's just flapping around,
his finger.
And I was like,
"You idiot, give it to me."
And then I did one pass,
and I chopped off
the tip of my finger, too,
and then I dragged him
to the emergency room.
-We have a photo.
-I brought him to the E.R.
-We have a photo of you guys.
That's you at the hospital.
-I brought him so we could
get special treatment.
I drag John everywhere
so I can get better treatment.
-Winners, man. Thumbs up,
and a finger up like,
"Hey, number one, man."
-Yep.
-Hey, pal.
I want to show you something.
Look at this.
I want to talk about
the Cravings Shop.
-Aah! Yes!
-Dude, talk to me about this.
-The chocolates are, honestly,
so incredible.
They're all my recipes inside
a Compartes chocolate bar,
which is already, like, so --
I learned that I fell in love
with white chocolate.
Theirs is so creamy
and delicious.
And my famous banana bread
is crumbled up into it.
And carrot cake.
And it's just so delicious.
We have, you know, the crystals
that are so much fun to wear.
I decided in this pandemic
that you're wearing a mask,
and I'm just very into
wearing something
with some kind of flair,
and so we did
these beautiful crystals.
My friend, Nova, did them,
and they're so awesome.
And, honestly, they're not
just for Coachella anymore,
I decided.
I want to actively wear
crystals.
-Let me see.
Are they hard to wear?
-[ Laughs ] I love you.
-Let's see.
-It's beautiful!
-Oh, thank you.
-Oh, my God! See?
-It's good. I like it.
And it's, like, kind of subtle,
but it's beautiful,
and, honestly,
it makes me feel good.
I love it.
-Don't you just feel better?
-Dude, I do feel better.
-Chrissy, sales are down.
-Wait. Sales are down.
Take the crystals off, Jimmy.
Exactly.
You don't want me as a model.
I'll tell you what, though.
I don't know if a lot
of people realize how much work
goes into these things,
to even have your name
on one thing.
I know you. We've known
each other for a long time now.
This is years in the making.
It's not like,
"Oh, hey, Chrissy,
in two months,
just put your name on this."
You go, "No, no, no.
I got to do this..."
-Yeah, I'm telling you.
It's years, years, years.
So when it does come out,
it seems like,
"Oh, surprise, it's a shop."
But, yeah, it's a lot
of hard work, so thank you.
It's my baby, and I -- Yeah,
we're a small little company,
and it's just really fun
to do it all.
-Good for you guys.
I got the latest addition
to the Cravings Shop,
and this is very you.
You have your own line of robes.
-[ Laughs ] I have robes.
That's the Basic Bitch Terry.
-[ Laughs ]
Is that what it's called?
-Yeah, it's just basic.
I didn't want bulky pockets.
I didn't want a tie
that would fall off.
I didn't want anything --
It's just a basic-ass --
[ Laughs ]
-Do you just wear this
around the house and stuff?
-Yes, it's so --
It's really short, too.
-It is tiny.
-No. Well, you're tall, so
it's going to be short on you.
But, yeah, you can roll up
the sleeves, wear your crystals.
I love you.
-No, this is fantastic.
It is a little short,
but I think --
You know what?
It's a little sexy.
-You're tall.
-This is --
No, no. This is the new --
-That's the thing.
Those robes are usually
bulky and lame,
so I wanted it
to have some sex appeal.
"I've given up,
but not entirely."
That's what it says.
That's a robe that screams
"I've given up,
but not entirely."
-I love the Basic Bitch Terry.
You have the cookbook.
You have all this cooking stuff.
Will there ever be
a Chrissy Teigen restaurant?
-Oh, my God! There is --
We are chatting about it
right now,
and I have looked
at some incredible spaces.
I don't know if it's so much
a restaurant as it is,
you know, a sitdown,
fast, casual establishment.
But I have dreams of, like,
a beautiful mezzanine
and John playing the piano
and it raining down
on the block.
I mean, I really -- I just want
to pretty much live there
and take pictures
with people and -- Yeah.
-I think this is a good start
right here. Congrats.
Chrissy Teigen, everybody.
Check out her Cravings Shop
at cravingsbychrissyteigen.com.